jean michel vous êtes pour l'obligation
vaccinale je suis pour parce que c'était
pratiquement le cas déjà parce que le
pass sanitaire ça représentait président
et patrick ont déjà un pass vaccinale
sol si on veut rester chez soi ne plus
bouger ne plus aller au restaurant du
plaza au cinéma ne plus sortir au
théâtre etc on était obligé de se
vacciner donc à partir donc c'était une
obligation qui ne lisaient pas son nom
donc à partir mais on ne le disait pas
son nom autant dire clairement autant se
faire vacciner sauf pour les enfants je
vais pas pour l'obligation pour les
enfants voilà parce que voilà ça je suis
un peu long mais voilà je trouve que les
enfants ça nécessite pas laisser aux
parents tout cas de la décision ce n'est
pas à l'état de décider pour nos enfants
voilà mais pour le reste ça existe et
pratiquement moi je voulais pas me faire
vacciner mais j'ai pas le choix donc
voilà donc c'est une obligation enfin
voilà pour les gens qui voulaient pas me
le font quand même un tableau contre
vraiment contre contre contre contre
parce que
justement si on est obligé de faire la
vaccination alors que là il nous donne
un vaccin qui est même pas fiable à 100%
ils le disent eux-mêmes les flammes à
peu près à 90% c'est normal que les gens
ils ont peur les gens ils se plaignent
d'un vaccin ils veulent pas se mettre ça
dans le corps et au lieu de les
sensibiliser il préfère les restes reine
de liberté c'est pour moi c'est une
connerie les gens c'est normal qu'ils
ont pété un plomb dans les rues tout
casser dans les rues c'est normal c'est
comme si j'ai pas moi j'ai pas comment
dire ça mais c'est comme si on est
capable of solace et comme si c'est
comme si quoi c'est comme si non
franchement je sais pas
c'était de la merde bah ouais c'est un
but contre d'habitude j'ai pas envie de
voyager je veux partir je ne sais où je
veux pas faire le vaccin je fais un test
pcr ces bons réglé je passe et puis
c'est tout l'âge et on oblige les gens à
faire avec ça je vaccine les âges et les
trois doses j'ai rien contre ça moi je
suis vacciné j'ai donné mon corps c'est
tout le problème c'est que les gens là
qui sont
mais ça nous regarde
japon là il faut les comprendre d'à côté
volet comprend city mais les violences
et que c'était un gouvernement bien sûr
pour les noms comprends cette colère est
compréhensible et c'est ce que c'est ce
que disait jean michel maire tout à
l'heure c'est que c'est une obligation
réelle mais on ne nous le dit pas
clairement toute la politique du
gouvernement c'est non bien sûr
l'obligation vaccinale de bain de sang
alors que dans les faits on est
concrètement obligé de se faire balayer
plus si on veut continuer à bord et
sociale si on veut continuer à
travailler si on veut continuer à vivre
tout simplement et là où je rejoins
pablo c'est qu'effectivement ce vaccin
ne n'empêche pas la transmission à
valence nice de le tracter virus il
empêche simplement les personnes
vaccinées 2 potentiellement développer
des formes graves mais il ne fait rien
contre la contre la contamination contre
la propagation du virus donc l'imposer
comme ça à des jeunes comme pablo ou
d'autres qui n'ont rien de qui aucun
risque a priori a priori non mais là oui
mais s'ils le souhaitent je ferai les
formes graves et réduit le risque
d'avoir rien à voir avec lui quand même
il ya des hôpitaux avec mes folies mais
après je monte mon pourrait aussi
hypocrite que le que la politique du
gouvernement sur la vaccination malade
cet hypocrite donc oui je vais l'être ce
soir mon réalité moi je suis comme comme
pas buzz et donner mon corps à la
science
c'est moi j'en dis le chat était trop
vieux gens me l'ont pris quand même
non je suis je suis pro science et j'ai
pris la décision de bex mettent en actes
de santé donc moi je considère que c'est
une décision individuelle moi j'ai fait
le choix de me vacciner mais je vais pas
l'obliger aux gens après comme l'a très
bien dit j'en
passe déjà à une obligation vaccinale si
on nous l'avait dit clairement avec des
arguments qui aurait pu être audible la
difficulté d'accès au vaccin pour
certaines populations
voilà on aurait pu l'entendre le
problème c'est qu'on nous dit pas donc
mon tour il est aussi pautric que que le
que la politique du gouvernement sur le
sujet la vaccination est déjà
obligatoire dans de nombreux pays en
autriche en italie pour les 50 ans et
plus c'est en projet en allemagne le
québec interdit carrément la vente
d'alcool et de cannabis aux personnes
qui ne sont pas vaccinés le canada dans
son entièreté va encore plus loin car
les personnes qui perdent leur travail
parce qu'ils n'ont pas été vaccinés et
qui du coup ne peuvent plus travailler
au contact des gens ne touche pas les
allocations chômage si jamais ils sont
virés à cause du covin ça va très très
loin en france on est carrément presque
les plus laxistes sur cette question
sofia tués contre cette obligation
vaccinale contre c'est un grand mot
parce qu'en fait c'est comme il l'a dit
on c'est un choix individuel après moi
j'aime être content parce qu'en vue de
ma situation vous pouvez comprendre que
le vaccin c'est une complication pour
moi
ils disent que les symptômes qu'on fait
après le vaccin ainsi c'est une douleur
à la jambe il faut direct se rendent aux
urgences ils disent que les symptômes où
il faut se rendre à l'hôpital après la
vaccination c'est des douleurs à la
jambe moi je devrais le faire sur la
jambe donc je suis assez réticente j'ai
pas vous mentir pour moi c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué que les autres sur donc
voilà après faut prendre cas par cas
c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il faut
pas obliger passe vaccinale parce que
c'est pas pour tout le monde facile
absolument d'accord avec sofia archi
contre non mais c'est une obligation
mais c'est une honte la manière dont on
nous soumet en fait à se passe vaccinale
c'est à dire que à quel moment on retire
l'alternative du test pcr du test
antigénique gratuit c'est à dire que
l'étau se resserre de plus en plus c'est
ce qui était prévu l'an depuis le début
c'est comme ça que ça devait se passer
les gens en fait moi je discute aussi
avec là je suis allé à euro disney a pas
très longtemps raconte
l'importance à ce qu'en fait le
personnel qui travaille là bas m'ont dit
en fait soit on se fait vacciner soit on
est viré 120 indemnités c'est ce dont
vous parliez tout à l'heure agathe donc
il y à des milieux où les gens se sont
virés sans indemnité aujourd'hui en
france ces graphistes déjà auront bien
sûr toucher l'allocation chômage une
fois au chantage mais christian estrosi
l'a encore plus loin car il a pris la
parole je sois sûr elle d'ailleurs ce
matin même en disant justement que pour
les non vaccinés qui perdaient leur
travail parce qu'il refusait de s'y
soumettre et donc au contact de public
si jamais ils perdaient leur travail en
raison de l'âne de leurs noms volonté de
se faire vacciner les héros plus
d'allocations chômage tient du
top-100 balle pour le personnel soignant
aussi c'est pareil on était là à les
applaudir ah ouais super et c'est
aujourd'hui s'ils ne sont pas vaccinés
et son foutu à la porte pareil avec zéro
balle on parle pas aussi des
restaurateurs qui n'étaient pas
éligibles pour les aides de l'état c'est
zéro balle aussi donc un moment donné il
va y avoir un soulèvement de la
population ça commence ça monte tout
doucement on n'est pas dans la dictature
moi j'aime pas ce mot là parce que
effectivement on vit pas dans une
dictature mais on est dans l'anti
libéralisme et sa diction dont tu
parlais pablo ssmi lautner de toi ouais
voilà c'est ça moi je dirais c'est une
dictature moderne non mais la dictature
s'est passé d'habiter dans une digue
ouais ben je le souhaite à personne mais
c'est ce qui est un peu en train de se
passer on nous prive de liberté les gens
eux ils ont des droits ils ont choix
s'ils veulent pas faire un vaccin c'est
leur droit et bappa près par contre je
suis pas contre le fait qu'après faut
assumer si demain la personne ne veut
pas se faire vacciner et qui lui arrive
un malheur
mais pablo les obligations il y en a
déjà été obligé de mettre à sentir de
sécurité tu veux dire mais voilà sinon
que ça demain j'en ai pas fait rejouer
en fait assez de ma faute bah oui décidé
pas on a dit ce qu'on aime
bien fait des gens comme le ms
l'aviez-vous mieux convaincre que
contraindre mois ci deux membres
assurent pour nous car encore une fois
si on me rassure on me dit tu peux faire
le vaccin sur un sur les gens y aura
aucun souci moi je me lance même avec ce
manque 2 et dago jc
rend obligatoire comme ça il faut le
faire sinon vous pourrez pas sortir ne
pourrez pas vous rendre au restaurant
vous pouvez pas non là on a un président
de la république dit je vais continuer à
emmerder non vaccinés non cotation on a
compris la politique dans quel sens elle
est allée à laisser l'assemblée c'est
vrai qu'on a on a compris que le lien
patrimoine aixois ne comptez pas sur
lennon va l'emmener pour être élu voilà
exactement la vraie problématique vous
l'avais dit la getz et la proche moi
j'aurais aimé plus de pédagogie parce
que comme je comme jeudi sur ceux qui ne
sont pas vaccinés il n'y a pas de dents
dans d'anti vax en primaire il n'y a pas
de complotiste comment comme on veut
forcément dire il ya aussi des gens qui
ont des craintes qui ont des peurs il
faut les entendre plus de pédagogie il
ya aussi des territoires il ya des
inégalités en fait même dans la
vaccination des territoires où il ya
moins de vacciner que d'autres mais pas
par pas forcément parce qu'ils parce
qu'ils sont réfractaires parce qu'ils se
rencontrent c'est ce qu'ils ont il faut
une infirmière qui vient sur place pour
des personnes âgées notamment que c'est
pas forcément facile on avait hirson
plateau des pmp de daniel moreau qui
disait que pour sa mère de 91 ans elle
avait dû attendre plus d'un mois pour
qu'une infirmière vient de vacciner sa
grand-mère sa mère pardon donc voilà et
c'est l'exemple type voilà donc bon
coach et moi je suis totalement d'accord
avec malek à des gens qui ont un réel
phobie du vaccin faut pas l'oublier une
phobie je veux dire des fois ça peut
être rationnel et l'irrationnel mais
c'est une phobie ne faut pas les
contraindre ce sera encore moins les
encourage à le faire il ya toujours un
gagnant qui ont une peur cette fois ci
ra du vaccin je pense par exemple à ma
mère qui a fait ses deux premières doses
que de refaire sa troisième qui a une
équipe des stups eu l'air à la suite du
second vaccin les préfets les
professionnels de santé pardon ne
voulais pas le signaler à la
pharmacovigilance disais non mais c'est
pas comme ça et c'est alors c'est sûr ça
à cause de ça il ya énormément d'effets
secondaires
du coup il ya plein de gens qui ne le
signale pas parce que c'est très long à
signaler mais si on recense tous les
effets secondaires il ya deux fois plus
de dallaire d'effets secondaires que
avec tous les médicaments réunies en une
seule année donc c'est deux fois plus
c'est énorme on n'a pas deux forcément
de recul sur cette action après il ya
des gens qui disent oui mais aussi les
effets à long terme du téléphone on ne
sait pas et cetera donc ce qu'ils disent
oui on n'a pas de recul sur le vaccin
c'est n'importe quoi
alors on a le coeur expérimenté quant à
moi j'ai pas parlé j'ai droit de parler
c'est a beaucoup parlé non j'ai pas
compris mais le recul mais ça lui oui je
te coupe la parole l'absence de chef
s'il n'y en ait pas mais on dit qu'on va
passer de leur passé et nous on a passé
un match est vraiment là bas c'est
rochus et marron fighter iv sorti le
vaccin par centime viagra et pas besoin
de recul tout le monde s'est jeté sur
les boîtes de vie
[Applaudissements]
la comparaison du vaccin et du viagra
merci pour ce moment de science hui
entre l'uci et comme vous l'avez vu jean
michel mr a une expertise sur le viagra
les
interventions alors pour résumer on est
contre le fait d'obliger une partie ou
toute la population à se vacciner mais
concrètement comment ça va se mettre à
réaliser dans nos vies la concrètement
demain on refuse de faire la troisième
dose en france on perd son pass
sanitaire donc c'est à dire que le petit
qr codes personnels vaccinale on perd ce
petit qr code qui nous permettait donc
d'aller au cinéma d'aller au musée
d'aller dans les restaurants fallait
travailler surtout talent et travail
c'est certain que ça va une profession
et on va chez soi du coup c'est ça on va
chez soi on fait un faux pas exactement
ce dont j'ai plein de paul qui font
défaut je suis contre moi j'ai un flash
back familiale a plein qui sera malek
défaut donc même dans mes potes en avait
énormément il ya des statistiques sur
les faux parce qu'ils sont énormes
aujourd'hui commence à sortir
apparemment il y avait 30 % ne faut pas
c'est quand même profits recule donc
c'est c'est beaucoup et c'est vrai que
ont tous un peu les gens à aller dans
une espèce de fraude ce qui est très
dommage si on avait gardé cette
alternative de tests pcr de pas
sanitaire qui était déjà ah bon un petit
peu caduque certes mais qui au moins
aider à lutter contre cette pandémie
c'est vrai qu'à appartement on se dit ok
le gouvernement fait ce qui peut aussi
donc il faut aller dans ce sens là aussi
elle appelle toujours de dire non mais
ça ne va pas mais là il ya plus cette
alternative c'est à dire que c'est fini
on peut plus faire de pc et on peut plus
faire dans tigenix et soit allé trois
doses soit et au ban de la société le
problème c'est qu'à une grande majorité
de français qui sont allés faire leurs
doses et et qui ont joué le jeu et le
problème c'est qu'avec ce genre de de
comportement c'est à dire de dire qu'on
en mer des antilles vax de vouloir faire
le pass vaccinale et ben on va avoir
beaucoup plus de réticents pour faire le
l'a22 rappelle alors que moi je suis pas
aussi catégorique que que charlotte je
pense qu'il ya aussi un bénéfice au bac
111 pour ceux qui sont à risque il ya la
bascule
mais le problème c'est qu'on va voir
beaucoup plus de réfractaires sur le
rappel et et apprendre à nous faire la
leçon et puis combien de la belle
combien de rappel on va avoir c'est ça
combien de doses on va avoir au bout
d'un moment ça parle de cas individus
moi même je me posais la question pour
moi là j'ai joué le jeu comme l'a dit
malek j'ai fait mes deux premières doses
j'ai fait la troisième par pure
obligation sinon je ne peux plus revenir
sur ce plateau et je ne peux plus rien
faire de ma vie mais si on me demande
une autre dans trois mois dans six mois
cinq fois par an je pense que je vais
faire partie de ceux qui descendront
dans la rue et qui diront c'est plus
possible c'est impossible de vivre comme
ça on va voir bien sûr comment ça évolue
merci d'avoir donné votre avis sur ce
sujet
[Applaudissements]